Johnstown Pennsylvania one of the
overlooked bygone cities that made
Donald Trump president the mines and
mills that once filled these valleys
with smoke and jobs haven't been
resurrected as he promised things were
hardly thriving here before coronavirus
but life in lockdown has brought this
city to a complete standstill giving
people plenty of time to observe how the
man they elected is handling the crisis
that will define his presidency so you
feel Donald Trump's briefings have been
informative yes very much so living
alone during lockdown gale is feeling
fatigue she misses her church she misses
company she's been watching the man she
voted for closely have you ever worried
throughout all of this that Donald Trump
is putting his own political interest in
terms of the economy over people's
health no no not at all because I think
for the most part he has been listening
to his elfin health experts on his on
his team but it's a dual edged sword
you know if the economy is ruined we're
going to suffer that decades from now
and people will die just as if they had
the virus because poverty does kill
people what went through your mind when
he floated the idea of injecting
disinfectant and he did that
tongue-in-cheek at did he i I believe so
yes indeed the tone seemed pretty
serious sometimes he does that I mean
I've been at at least one rally of his
and okay even if it was a joke is it the
time for jokes well I think if you took
everybody's comments and wrote them down
there are times that maybe in an
inappropriate comment he's not everybody
he's the president in a global pandemic
that's true well I took it as a joke I
was flabbergasted
I actually just was like really know
he's yeah he is serious he's actually
serious he's going with this Tammy also
voted for Trump in 2016 but for her
Corona
virus is the last straw she says his
daily briefings have offered her no
reassurance they are in my opinion a
platform for him to feed his ego that
he's in charge that he can be rude to
people and he can also put everyone else
down and how they've done everything
wrong and he's done everything right and
nothing is his fault and he takes no
accountability for anything but Tammy
says she senses that her change of heart
isn't the prevailing sentiment for
plenty of people Trump is still the
savior his impatience to reopen the
economy is deeply felt in places like
Johnstown where unemployment was already
70 percent above the national average
but the polls say most people support
ongoing restrictions keeping families
safe is the priority rushing things
could be catastrophic for Americans and
for the man who's leading them Amanda
Walker Sky News Johnstown Pennsylvania